before we wrap up drew's newshour we've  got one more story that we love so much  that it's going in our little yellow box  people reports that a toy company called  pibba rafi is creating some absolutely  adorable tributes to real life rescue  animals with their rescue plushies oh my  gosh all these little doggies fit in the  palm of your hand and sales help raise  money for shelters  and rescues oh look at that and they all  have their own amazing story this is  petey and he was found on the side of  the road as a puppy  he's a tripod and he now travels around  as a therapy dog i love you petey i love  you  i have to say that this is definitely a  company i'll be supporting this holiday  absolutely  rescue animals so important  [Music]  you